اكد فدان قتال نائب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان واشنطن تواصل مطالبه الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بانهاء
الاقتتال في السودان وكرر باتل تحذير
الخارجيه للامريكيين من السفر الى السودان
في ظل الازمه الحاليه
نواصل مطالبه القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم السريع بانهاء القتال الذي
يعرض جميع المدنيين للخطر كما نكرر
تحذيرنا للمواطنين الامريكيين من السفر
الى السودان
قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم جون
بيير ان واشنطن تواصل اجراء محادثات مع
طرفي النزاع في السودان لانهاء القتال
بشكل فوري ودون شروط اضافت في مؤتمر صحفي
ان الوضع في السودان متقلب وان الولايات
المتحده تركز على مساعده الامريكيين
الراغبين في المغادره
في اجراء هذه المحادثات فريق الامن القومي
الامريكي على اتصال مباشر مع قياده الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لحثيهما على
انهاء الاعمال العدائيه فورا ودون شروط
كما نتشاور من كثب مع شركاء الاقليميين
وغيرهم منذ مده نحث الجانبين على الالتزام
بشكل كامل بوقف اطلاق النار وتمديده الوضع
في السودان متقلب ونركز على مساعده
الامريكيين الراغبين في المغادره
قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان تواصل
المكثف مع طرفي الصراع في السودان ساهم في
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار اضاف كيربي ان
واشنطن تواصل تسهيل مغادره الامريكيين برا
وجوا وقال ان واشنطن تتطلع الى انهاء
الصراع في السوق الى انتهاء الصراع في
السودان وعدم امتداده الى مناطق اخرى